Musik Herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe des Podcast-Ufos, Folge 33. Wir sind wahnsinnig aufgeregt, wir sind so aufgeputscht, wir haben 50 Red Bull getrunken, weil diese Folge gut werden muss. Ja, wir haben die letzten zwei Folgen, also die letzten beiden Folgen waren so ein bisschen unsere Katastrophenfolgen. Ich glaube, ab drei wird es kritisch, oder? Ich glaube, zwei Ausrutscher kann man sich erlauben. Das hatten wir schon mal, damals haben wir von einer handfesten Krise gesprochen, jetzt ist es wieder so. Das waren sehr dunkle Zeiten, ich erinnere mich noch dunkler. Ich glaube, wir haben beide in Mordor gelebt zu der Zeit. Keine Ahnung, macht keinen Sinn der Gäste. Ich bin sehr aufgeregt und ich war so aufgeregt, dass ich, da muss ich 19 Uhr verabredet, mittlerweile haben wir 19. 20 und ich habe die ersten 20 Minuten komplett im Monolog gehalten und habe, weil ich meine Gedanken loswerden wollte, habe ich es einfach aufgenommen. Die besten Gangschirm mal rausgehauen alleine. Und ihr wisst zu diesem Zeitpunkt jetzt schon, ob wir es vorher drangeschnitten haben oder nicht. Ich werde es sich vorhin vorspielen und wenn er sagt, ach fuck, jetzt bist du wahnsinnig, dann lasse ich es sein. Vielleicht wisst ihr aber jetzt schon, dass es einfach drangeschnitten wurde. Ich bin gespannt. Als Sie sich fragen, wer gerade hier die ganze Zeit zu Ihnen spricht, es ist natürlich Steffen Tesco, der heute mal wieder da ist für die neuen Folge des Podcast-UFO. Tesco, genau, das ist mein Name und du bist, weiß ich nicht, wie heisst du denn nochmal? Florentin, genau, das ist dein Name. Ja, wir haben eine Menge neuer Zuhörer bekommen tatsächlich und es fühlt sich so ein bisschen wie Neuanfang an irgendwie, gerade in Deutschland ist ja sowieso gerade so die Stimmung, man nimmt Leute auf, kommt alle hier, wir nehmen euch in den Arm, alle müssen ein bisschen näher rücken und auch beim Podcast Ufo ist das so. Es kommen neue Leute dazu, die natürlich alle herzlich angenommen werden und wir sind eine grosse Familie geworden. Erst mal die Regeln kurz klar machen. Die erste Regel, man spricht über das Podcast Ufo, das ist ganz wichtig, wenn ihr mit euren Freunden beisammen seid, einen lockeren Abend macht und zusammen irgendwie eine Runde Dog-TV schaut. Ich wollte möglichst viele Insider reinbringen. Die die Leute gar nicht verstehen. Genau. Hä, warum war das jetzt lustig? Ich habe gelacht, aber ich weiß nicht warum. Ich habe einfach gelacht plötzlich. Ganz wichtig ist, dass ihr Leuten erzählt, dass es uns gibt und spread the word, spread the word. Ich finde es auch gut, dass das Erste, was wir machen, nachdem wir erfolgreich geworden sind, wir betteln, unsere Zuhörer an, noch erfolgreicher zu werden. Irgendwann ist es auch gut, Stefan, irgendwann haben wir es auch erreicht. Ich hoffe auch, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, was? Zu diesen tausend Followern haben wir uns hart durchgekämpft. Ich weiß noch, wir haben angefangen im stillen Kämmerlein dachten, oh, vier Hörer, wie geil wäre das denn, wenn zumindest unsere Eltern uns einmal zuhören würden in unserem Leben. Sie haben uns unser ganzes Leben lang ignoriert. Wenn sie uns hier zumindest anhören würden, das ist immer noch nicht der Fall, aber trotzdem haben tausend Fremde irgendwie den Weg gefunden, uns zu hören. Von daher, ich glaube, es reicht auch. Ich habe eine sehr große Familie, ich wollte jetzt nur sagen, ich habe eine sehr große Familie, es dauert ein bisschen, bis die News angekommen ist bei allen. Das heißt aber auch, dass wir jetzt eine dritte Klasse Hörer haben tatsächlich. Also das heißt, der innere Kreis wird immer breiter, der innere Zirkel, Inner Circle, wird immer grösser, unser Top-Kommentator, Inner Circle, die Hörer erster Klasse. Was ist das eigentlich? Es ist ein sehr schlechter Virus, der sich darauf spezialisiert hat plötzlich. So ein eigenständiger gewordener Virus vielleicht.
Lass uns mal drauf eingehen. Also, wir haben auf der Facebook-Seite einen User, der ab und zu bei unseren Posts kommentiert. Sein Name ist Inner Circle. Ihr könnt ihn ja mal selber nachgucken, was er so macht und seine Nachrichten finden. Und sein Ding ist irgendwie, das ist sein Thing, er schreibt sehr gerne in Englisch darunter nice. Er kommentiert ausschliesslich in Englisch und er kommentiert auch auf amerikanischen UFO-Seiten, also die sich tatsächlich mit UFOs beschäftigen. Das heißt, meine Vermutung ist ein bisschen, dass er denkt, wir wären eine deutsche UFO-Seite. Und um uns so ein bisschen zu unterstützen, weil wir offensichtlich keine Follower haben, versucht er so ein bisschen, obwohl er den Inhalt nicht versteht, so möglichst allgemeine Kommentare zu posten, so wie, hey, super post, was einfach ist, weil sie es nicht posten. Er will ja irgendwie da drin sein, so wie so ein Freund, der immer versucht, der immer beim Gespräch nicht so ganz mitkommt, aber so Wörter reinbringt, um sich in der Gespräch zu halten. Und in der Sprache versucht, Komplimente zu machen. Wie so ein Austauschstudent, der irgendwie versucht, Teil des Teams zu sein, aber irgendwie es nicht so richtig schafft. Es ist ein bisschen traurig, aber um ihn so ein bisschen mit ins Boot zu holen, hat er mal einmal nice gefragt, plötzlich, aber er hat auch mal eine Frage stellen wollen, nice, hat er gefragt und dann haben wir einfach mal zurückgeschrieben, nice, yeah. Also wenn ihr jemanden was Gutes tun wollt, liked einfach mal seine Kommentare auf unserer Facebook-Seite. Ja, schreibt, ich glaube, er wird ein wichtiger Teil unserer Community Community, genauso wie also Hörer erster Klasse, die von Anfang an dabei waren, die sich noch durch Folge 10 gekämpft haben, durch unseren ersten kompletten Totalausfall, die noch bei der Möbel- und Magnete-Folge dabei waren. Nein, nein, das war eine Sternstunde. Magnete ist nach wie vor ein grosser Teil meines Lebens. Magnete ist ein wichtiges Thema. Ganz kurz, also das wollte ich nochmal einschmeißen. Und es wird auch eine normale Folge sein, das kann ich jetzt schon mal verraten. Und das heißt, mit den Rocket Beans, mit meinem Auftritt in Almost Daily kamen dann die Hörer zweiter Klasse. Höhere dritter Klasse ist Nils Ruf. Alleine hat er als einziger Mensch den Rang des höherer dritter Klasse. Das war ganz gruselig. Man muss vielleicht nochmal dazusprechen. Für einen ganz kurzen Moment, für einen kurzen Augenblick, für einen Hauch, Hauch der Zeit, im Wind der Zeit, für ein kurzes Zeitloch, fand Nils Ruf das Podcast-Ufo gut, aber dann ist ihm ganz schnell eingefallen, nee, ist doch nicht so mein Ding. Er hat es relativ schnell gemerkt und hat es dann wieder entliked. Das führte dazu, dass ich sehr lange auf meinem Handy den Satz stehen hatte, Nils Ruf gefällt als Podcast-UFO, in Ekstase verfallen bin, spontan einen Truppsausanfall bekommen habe, als er dann gemerkt hat, dass das nicht mehr so der Fall ist und er offensichtlich nicht das Podcast-Ofo geliked hat. Das war sehr traurig. Und er hat jetzt relativ schnell sofort wieder entliked, das heißt, diese Phase ist vorbei. Aber hast du das manchmal, dass du auf deinem Handy eine Notification hast, die so schön ist, dass du sie gar nicht anwählen willst, weil du sie noch ein bisschen genießen willst? Habe ich meistens, wenn mein zweiter Account ... Mein erster Account liked. Ja, genau. Aber was ich ganz lustig fand war, Twitter hat beim Podcast-Ufo angefangen, uns zu gratulieren für eine bestimmte Anzahl von Followern. Also sie haben bei 300 gesagt, herzlichen Glückwunsch, du hast jetzt 300 Follower, bei 400 auch noch, und jetzt haben wir die tausend geknackt und es kam keine Nachrichten mehr. So haben wir so, okay, jetzt fahrt man wieder ein bisschen runter. Die Twitter-Friendzone. Fahrt man jetzt wieder ein bisschen runter, das ist wieder langsam ein bisschen gruselig. Die gönnen uns das nicht, die gönnen uns die tausend, haben sie nicht mehr gegönnt. Die neunhundert waren auch okay. Obwohl, eigentlich ist das ja das Zeichen, dass man wirklich Erfolg hat, wenn einem Leute nicht mehr gratulieren. Wenn man einen Oscar gewinnt, die Leute sagen, willst du mit unserem Auto nach Hause fahren oder fährst du bei Beyonce mit oder wir machen was, also klassische Oscar-Gespräche, wenn die Leute einem nicht mehr gratulieren, sondern einfach als völlig natürlich hinnehmen, ja klar, wir sind da hin und er hat gewonnen, er hat Magnete dabei und alles klar, wunderbar, kein Problem. Das ist eigentlich dann der Punkt, wenn man nicht mehr Gratulation bekommt. Und ich habe, ich muss ja mal sagen, bei mir auf Twitter läuft nicht schlecht,
ich komme bald an die 10.000-Follower-Grenze und mein grösster Wunsch wäre es, wenn mir Twitter nicht gratulieren würde. Dann würde ich mir denken, ja klar, wenn das einfach stillschweigend hingenommen wird. Oder wenn Twitter plötzlich anfängt, dich zu bedrohen irgendwie. Also wenn du nicht sofort damit aufhörst. Du machst das ganze Ruf von Twitter, machst du da nieder, hör einfach auf damit. Ich habe auch mir vorgenommen, wenn du irgendwie so einen Tweet raushaust, so einen arroganten, oh, ich habe jetzt 10.000 Follower, yeah, geil, weiß nicht, was du da tolles schreibst, ich werde dich sofort entfolgen, damit der Tweet da steht, während du noch 9.999 Follower hast. Aber der 10.000 wird ein Knallertweet, der wird der absolut beste Tweet aller Zeiten, der wird großartig. Ach so, dann irgendwie auch, das ist ein bisschen so wie diese Folge heute, der muss gut werden, genau wie diese Folge sehr gut werden muss. Für die, die jetzt erst reinhören und unseren Rat befolgt haben, die letzte Folge nicht zu hören, kurz nochmal der Recap, es war mega awkward, wir hatten ein Stand-Up-Comedian zu Gast, es hat nicht funktioniert, das Gespräch kam nicht zustande einfach, wir haben Bälle hinzugespielt, die nicht zurückkamen, wir haben aber auch direkt. die falschen Bälle fürs Spiel war. Wir haben Tischtennis gespielt und haben Medizinbälle geworfen. Wir haben direkt auch Bälle einfach direkt ins Netz gespielt. Die Bälle kamen einfach nicht an. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Nee, es war ganz gruselig. Aber wir haben es in der Folge auch besprochen. Ich glaube, da wurde alles gesagt zu dem Thema. Ich würde jetzt gerne eine Zusammenfassung der Zusammenfassung machen. Ach so. Aber Entschuldigung. Nein, können wir nicht. Das war sich schon. Wie gesagt, Programmplan ausdrucken. Ja, habe ich schon. Das habe ich schon. Das war jetzt abgeschlossen. Ich weiß nicht, was du jetzt sagen wolltest. Ach so. Ne, da hat die Community sich tatsächlich auch mal tatsächlich sehr starke Rückmeldungen bekommen, was immer schön ist, weil wir auch in der Folge um Feedback gefragt haben. Vielen Dank und ich glaube, darum soll es heute auch so ein bisschen gehen um euch, weil wir sind jetzt schon recht lange dabei und wir haben schon viel durchgemacht und ihr wart immer dabei. Und deswegen wollen wir heute auch mal Danke sagen, dass ihr dabei seid, Nils Ruf, vor allem, dass du dabei warst. Vielen Dank, Nils Ruf. Und wenn du uns hörst und vielleicht ganz okay findest, dann mach doch einfach ein Gefällt mir daraus und dann like uns auch mal bei Facebook. Also ich weiß nicht, wenn das, wenn dein Name dafür immer stehen würde, das würde uns beiden wahnsinnig guttun einfach. Du kennst ihn doch irgendwoher, hast du mal gesagt. Ich bin ihm schon mal begegnet. Hast du dir das mega-awkward, Nils Ruf, Geschichte zu erzählen irgendwie? Also ich sag mal so, ich bin ja immer auf das, ich bin ja der Exzentrische, Exzentrische, ich bin ja der Typ. Exzentrische, ich denke mir Wörter aus, wie ich bin. Der Exzentrische. Der Exzische, ja, ich bin ja der Typ, wo man sagt, wo man nicht lange drüber reden muss. Florentin, wie war das nochmal? Ach ja, das war der Typ, der immer ein Stirnband trägt. Ah ja, klar, das ist der, der im Kino immer ganz links, ganz vorne sitzt. Ich bin einfach so ein Typ, den kann man gut einführen. Wenn man eine Kurzgeschichte über mich schreibt, ich bin in der ersten Zeile vollends charakteristisch. Was mich daran stört, ist das Wort Magnete kommt noch nicht drin vor. Magnete sind noch nicht so ein großer Teil deines Lebens. Das ist ja dein Signature-Move. Das ist genau wie Mahler Singer, die in Fight Club vorgestellt wird mit den Worten, Mahler Singer ist wie diese kleine Wunde an der Lippe, die heilen würde, die ganz schnell heilen würde, wenn man nicht ständig mit der Zunge an ihr rumspielen müsste. So wurde Mahler Singer eingegangen, wo ich mir dachte, wow, das ist eine Einführung. Wow, guter Film. Alter Vater, kann man sich aber auch gut jemand darunter vorstellen. Das ist ein Problem, das einfach zu lösen wäre, wenn das Problem selber nicht so viel Spaß machen würde. Mein Signature-Move ist leider ein anderer. Es ist mir nämlich neulich klar geworden, als ich mal wieder vor der U-Bahn stand. Ein grosser Teil meines Lebens verbringe ich in U-Bahn und im Supermarkt. Und da stand ich an der U-Bahn. Und was ich neulich sehr oft mache, dass mir da zuerst mal bewusst geworden ist, ich habe immer Kopfhörer im Ohr und höre Dinge und dann verheddert sich manchmal das Kabel oder es ist einfach nur wahnsinnig aufgerollt und dann lasse ich mein, dann halte ich das Kabel so und lasse das Handy daran runterbaumeln und dann lasse das Handy so lange drehen, bis sich das Kabel wieder entworfen hat. Aber es ist aber nicht verknotet, es ist nur verwirbelt. Es ist nur verwirbelt. Und
dadurch dreht sich mein Handy dann ganz schnell und Leute gucken mich immer
an und fragen sich, was macht er da?
Was macht er da, was will er damit bezwecken?
Und ich glaube, das hat noch niemand richtig verstanden, was ich da genau mache.
Aber das ist, glaube ich, mein Signature-Move.
Sehr uncool. Aber kann man sich manchmal nicht so auslösen.
Tatsächlich zum Thema Kopfhörer,
weil es gibt ja zwei Arten von Kopfhörer. Es gibt einmal
die symmetrischen,
die man sich sozusagen
vor dem Körper, links und rechts in die Hohen
steckt und dann die, die man noch so hinten
Vielen Dank. Weil es gibt ja zwei Arten von Köpfe. Es gibt einmal die symmetrischen, die man sich sozusagen vor dem Körper links und rechts in die Hohen steckt und dann die, die man noch so hinten um den Nacken bindet, die asynchronen, die asymmetrischen und denk, Kopf, lass mich nicht im Stich, streich nicht an den Kopf. Die asozialen. Die asozialen. Und ich benutze immer die asymmetrischen. Und deswegen tatsächlich hat mein Mitfond noch mal drauf angesprochen, dass es mein
zielischer Move ist, dass immer wenn ich meine Kopfhörer einstecke, dass ich da mit der
rechten Hand so lässig einmal so um meinen Kopf die Kopfhörer wirbele. Also wieder wirbeln spielen. Ich habe das lange nicht verstanden, dass man das hinterm Kopf machen muss. Man hat deswegen sehr lange Zeit meines Lebens einfach asymmetrische Kopfhörer wie symmetrische Kopfhörer getragen, was das für das immer so einen komischen Bommel hatte, so eine kleine Schlaufe. Und das war immer ein Signature-Move damals, so eine Schlaufe immer zu haben, wo man dann immer, wenn man irgendwie ausladende Bewegungen macht in der U-Bahn, wenn man Leute gerade schlägt oder so, dass man immer in dieser Schlaufe hängen bleibt, wenn man sich so das halbe Ohr rausreißt, wenn man alles in den Nübeln hängen bleibt. Ja, mir wurde so mal tatsächlich mein Handy ins Gleisbett geworfen. Da bin ich ausgestiegen aus der S-Bahn,
denk mir nichts Böses, und dann läuft so ein Typ
relativ nah an mir vorbei, wirklich
reibt an meinem Körper entlang,
an den Kopfhörern wird mein Handy
aus der Tasche gezogen, es fällt auf den
Bahnsteig und ins Gleisbett, also zwischen
S-Bahn und Bahnsteig.
Kam es so gerade?
Die S-Bahn stand gerade da,
weil ich ja gerade ausgestiegen war, aber dann fährt die S-Bahn weg und dann stehe ich da auf der Seite und mein Handy liegt im Gleisbett. Und die Geschichte habe ich im Podcast-Ufer schon mal erzählt. Welche Folge, weiß ich nicht, aber falls es jemand weiß, schreibt es in die Kommentare. Ich habe es schon vergessen. Geiler Teaser, wir müssen ja unseren Back-Catalog auch so ein bisschen anpreisen. Lass mich kurz meine Anekdote zu Nils Ruf erzählen, weil ich die jetzt gerade angefangen habe. Ich bin ja so einischer Typ, ne, und deswegen habe ich tatsächlich, als ich mal in Wien war, wollte ich mir eine Uhr
kaufen, eine Armbanduhr, weil ich nie eine Armbanduhr hatte, und das war auch noch die Zeit, wo man
Smartphones nicht so krass hatte, deswegen dachte ich mir, ich brauche eine Uhr. Und dann habe ich so eine
goldene Uhr gefunden, die komplett golden war, und ich dachte mir, ha, ist doch total geil, lustig,
ironisch, wenn ich eine komplett goldene Uhr habe, die war auch schon irgendwie uralt, made in West
Germany oder so, also die war schon bestimmt 600 Jahre alt, und die war allerdings eine Damenuhr,
Was ist das? wenn ich eine komplett goldene Uhr habe. Die war auch schon irgendwie uralt, made in West Germany oder so, also die war schon bestimmt 600 Jahre alt. Und die war allerdings eine Damenuhr, was ich nicht verstanden habe zu dem Zeitpunkt, weil ich Damen nicht kenne. Das ist ein komplett unbekanntes Konzept. Es gab für dich nur Eigenschlecht und Gnorms. Gnorm, ja. Versteht man nicht, aber guter Gag. Auf jeden Fall habe ich diese Uhr gekauft und dann habe ich sie meinen Freunden gezeigt und die, ja, das ist eine Damenuhr, du Depp. Und ich dachte mir so, ich weiß, aber es ist ja saulustig, oder nicht, dass ich eine Damenuhr habe. Und dann musste ich es auch durchziehen, weil du kannst nicht sowas bringen und dann einfach zwei zum Beispiel. Und du hast ein Kleid an, Florian, warum hast du ein Kleid an? Ja, genau. Du bist ein ganz anderer Mensch. Und dann 20 Minuten, wenn man 20 Minuten später die Uhr wieder ablegt, dann weiß man, man hat verloren. Das geht nicht. Deswegen muss man sie mindestens noch ein Jahr lang tragen, damit man vor seinen Freunden nicht blöd dasteht. Das denke ich mir auch immer an Karneval, wenn man sich mal wieder diese lustige Brille mit der großen Nase und dem Schnauzer aufsetzt und dann alle sagen, oh, ist das schon uncool. Und der Tag ist wirklich schon gelaufen, weil du von Leuten angebracht wirst, dass dein Kostüm nicht lustig ist. Und dann musst du es aber auch durchziehen, weil du denkst, ich kann es nicht einfach ablegen. Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, eine Mindestzeit, die man Dinge tragen muss. Oder auch auf einer Party, wenn du irgendwie einen Luftballon in der Hand hast, wenn du jemandem einen Luftballon gibst und du denkst, wie lange muss ich den jetzt halten, bevor ich ihn loswerde, weil das ist echt scheiße. Ja, vor allem, es ist auch wieder, irgendwann wird es auch wieder lustig. Also erst wenn die Leute anmachen, dann hör nicht sofort auf, sondern mach es vielleicht weiter, weil erst mal, vielleicht ist es lustig, wenn man über einen längeren Zeitraum das macht, zum Beispiel. Ich habe mal auf einer Weihnachts-, da war irgendwie so eine Feier und da habe ich jedem, habe ich jedem fröhliche Weihnachten gewünscht und das war am Anfang wahnsinnig awkward, aber am Ende, als ich dem ganzen Club frühe Weihnachten gewünscht habe, war es dann irgendwann wieder lustig. Also irgendwann werden Gags auch erst über die Zeit, müssen sie reifen, wie ein guter Wein oder so, wie ein guter Quark, keine Ahnung. Ja, genau, auf jeden Fall war diese Uhr dann immer wieder der Punkt von mich auslachen Situationen, allerdings war es dann so, dass ich in der Frank-Elster-Masterclass Nils Ruf interviewen konnte, weil wir sollten jeweils einen Typen interviewen und ich hatte Nils Ruf, fucking Nils Ruf und der Typ ist unglaublich schlagfertig und der hat mich komplett fertig gemacht im Interview, das war das erste Interview meines Lebens und er hat mich einfach komplett fertig gemacht. Geil, weil wenn du irgendwie so ein Furby bekommen hättest. Alle kriegen echt im Leben weh. Ja, du hast dieses Tamagotchi-Interview. Legen Sie mal hier hin. Ich habe heute mein Lieblings-Sombrero mitgebracht, stelle ich heute ein paar Fragen. Und Nils Ruf meinte dann so, ah, okay, cool, du hast, also ein super guter Gag eigentlich von Nils Ruff, super schlagfertig, er meinte, ah, okay, du hast die Damenuhr, damit du dir vorstellen kannst, wenn du dir einen runterholst, dass es eine Frau ist. Oh! Da dachte ich mir schon, wow, ey, das ist ein guter Gag und dann musste ich einfach in voller Demut diese Uhr ein für allemal ablegen, weil ich dachte mir, ja, Nils Ruff hat den Fluch gebrochen, das ist wie, wenn man von einem Frosch geküsst wird und dann irgendwie keiner, nicht mehr Prinzessin ist oder was auch immer. Und so war es bei Nils Ruf auch. Nils Ruf war da mein Frosch und deswegen habe ich die Uhr abgelegt. Ja, und seitdem liegt sie in der Kiste der vergessenen Dinge. Ja, ich finde aber auch gut, dass man... Genau wie die Packung Kondome, die ich mir gekauft habe, als ich 19 war. Also die Kiste der vergangenen Träume. Die laufen ab. Ich glaube, das ist nicht so wild. Ich glaube, die können ruhig ablaufen.
Ich finde es auch gut, dass wir Nils Ruf als unseren persönlichen Frosch des Lebens bezeichnen,
einfach auch weiterhin, auch bis Podcasts.
A new T-Shirt, neue T-Shirt-Idee.
Leute, wir haben schon eine neue T-Shirt-Idee.
Apropos, Leute, wir hauen demnächst T-Shirts raus.
Es ist wichtig, dass ihr auch deswegen, dass ihr einfach Leuten erzählt, dass das Podcast so-Ufo gibt, damit es vielleicht so eine T-Shirt-Kultur ist. Ich finde auch, vielleicht sollten wir so die neuen Che Guevara werden, werden's, Che Guevaras werden, einfach damit wir, damit unsere T-Shirts bekannter werden als der Podcast. Die T-Shirts müssen bekannter werden als das Produkt. Das finde ich tatsächlich sehr gut, das Che Guevara-Ufo. Aber ich dachte mir, wir machen so hardcore Insider, dass die teilweise sogar nur wirklich wir verstehen. Genau, die Hörer gefragt werden, was trägst du da eigentlich? Und einfach die Schulter hochgezogen. Keiner. Well, I don't know. So ein T-Shirt mit Das Schichterwock-Ufo. So, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist. Ich fand es gerade mega lustig. Ich habe getrunken, deswegen konnte ich nicht lachen, aber ich fand es mega lustig. Danke, dass du das mitselst. In einem Audiokommentar wird dann nochmal darauf eingegangen, warum wir genau das nicht. Das wollten wir auch mal machen. Wir müssen mal eine Folge besprechen. Es gibt ja diesen Effekt, den DJs auch haben. Wenn die was ins Mikrofon sagen, geht die Musik leiser. Don't drink and drive. Können darüber sprechen. Das sollten wir mal bei einer Folge machen, bei einer Podcast-Ufo-Folge machen, die wir komplett einfach als Audiokommentar
veröffentlichen. Das finde ich geil, aber
veröffentlichen wir dann nur den Audiokommentar oder
die Audiokommentar mit der Folge zusammen? Die Folge zusammen,
die fängt so an, dann wird die aber ein bisschen leiser, dann hört man,
wie wir dann drüber sprechen, über uns selber. So
overvoisen wir uns. Das wird dann wahnsinnig verwirrend,
weil wir jetzt wahrscheinlich auch auditiv
nicht richtig hinbekommen, auch im Programm,
dass das ein wenig leiser wird im Hintergrund und man hört
einfach vier Stimmen, zwei davon klingen immer gleich
und es ist einfach wahnsinnig wirrwarr.
Aber es wird ganz lustig für uns vielleicht mal.
Oder wir machen eine Folge, wo wir
eine Folge nehmen und eine Spur
löschen und dann macht jeder
eine einzelne Folge mit der
vorher aufgezeichneten Folge des anderen.
Ja, das haben wir auch schon mal. Ganz lustig eigentlich.
Doch, die Idee hatten wir auch schon mal.
Wir hatten früher wahnsinnig gute Ideen.
Ja. Ich schreibe es mal kurz auf, damit wir es nicht vergessen. Aber ich dachte, damit es Nils Ruf vielleicht noch mitbekommen ist, kann ich ja auch. Ach ja, den sollten wir ins Boot nehmen. Was wir auch noch sagen sollten, wir sind heute mal wieder bei Skype unterwegs, wir sind mal wieder nicht zusammen in einem Raum. Skype! Es ist mal wieder das gute alte Skype am Start und bislang klappt es ganz gut. Und was ich ganz geil fand, als ich mich auf die Folge vorbereitet habe,
indem ich Skype angemacht habe und gehofft habe, bitte und mir zwanghaft noch einen Gag überlegen wollte, irgendwie, du musst was zu erzählen haben, heute ist eine fucking wichtige Folge, hat Skype mir den besten Gag des Tages geliefert. Und zwar stand da Achtung! Dingelingeling. Der beste Gag des Tages.
Und zwar hat Skype gesagt, Skype macht mehr Spaß mit Freunden.
Haben die mir so als Tipp genannt, was ich gut fand.
Ah, da habe ich meine Zweifel.
Und ich finde, die sollten nicht schreiben, Skype macht mehr Spaß mit Freunden, sondern die sollten schreiben, ohne Freunde macht Skype gar keinen Spaß. Das ist furchtbar, das ist sogar mega gefährlich, wenn du mit fremden Leuten telefonierst und möglicherweise noch minderjährig bist. Das ist einfach auch gefährlich. Und ich finde, dann sollte man einfach auch dieses, wir sind eine Firma und haben diesen Auftrag, immer fröhlich zu klingen, Skype macht mehr Spaß mit Freunden, sollte man vergessen, einfach mal sagen, ohne Skype, ohne Freunde macht einfach, macht Skype mal keinen Spaß. Man sollte einfach mal drastisch eine Aussage raushauen, finde ich, als Skype. Das ist eigentlich auch eine gute Idee, mal Werbebotschaften umzudrehen. Also nicht Coca-Cola eiskalt geniessen, sondern Coca-Cola schmeckt warm, furchtbar scheiße. Eher schlecht, schmeckt lauwarm, eher scheiße. Dieser ganze Positivismus, der geht mir auf den Sack, muss man ein bisschen negativ sein. Und es ist auch einfach ehrlicher, weil ohne Freunde macht es wirklich gar keinen Spaß und es ist auch gefährlich. Und ich habe mich auch gefragt, an wen richtet sich das denn, dieses Zitat? An Leute, die keine Freunde haben, die werden dann auch auf Skype wieder schließen. Oder die einfach Skype schon seit Jahren benutzen und sich denken, ach, das ist ein gutes Programm, wunderbar, Farbe gefällt mir, ich kann mir einen Avatar aussuchen, perfekt, wunderbar, ich bin zufrieden, aber dann erst merken, Moment mal, Player 2 has entered the game.
Ist ein Gamechanger bei manchen Leuten, dieser Satz, Moment mal, was kann man denn hier alles noch machen?
Das fand ich sehr lustig, und da bin ich auch dankbar darüber, dass wenn man zwanghaft nach Gags sucht, dass das Leben einem einfach so entgegenschmeißt.
Skype greift einem unter die Arme.
Deswegen benutzen wir Skype und treffen uns
nicht privat.
Wollten wir nicht heute mal ein bisschen
auf die Community eingehen? Gerne.
Die uns auch immer sagen, dass der Podcast zu leise
ist. Also vielleicht habt ihr uns bis jetzt auch wieder nicht
verstanden, weil irgendwie auch wieder
irgendwo, weiss nicht, wo ihr auch immer seid am lauten Ort.
Aber das ist tatsächlich ein Problem, das uns genauso
stört wie euch. Ja, vor allem, woran liegt es denn? Also wir reden ganz normal laut ins Mikro, wir haben ganz normal lauten Ausschlag am Körper und ...
Ha ha ha, Ausschlag.
Verdammt, den konnte ich nicht liegen lassen.
Musikerwitz.
Ja, und irgendwie, aber wann hört es denn auf, eine normale Lautstärke zu haben, in welchem Prozess?
Ich finde es so gut, dass kurz nachdem du Skype gelobt hast, Skype jetzt abkackt bei mir gerade. Oh, fuck. Ja, ich höre die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage finde es so gut, dass kurz nachdem du Skype gelobt hast, Skype jetzt abkackt bei mir gerade. Oh, fuck. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt die beste Herangehensweise ist, einfach gar nicht mehr zu sprechen. Hallo? Eins, zwei? Hallo, ja, ich Skype bei mir gerade zusammen, kurz nachdem wir Skype gelobt haben. Ja, man darf das glaube ich nicht so oft nennen, sonst denkt niemand lästert über die, dann brechen die einfach das Telefonat einfach ab zwischendurch. Gehen einfach davon aus, dass es schlechtes gesagt wird, ja. Ja, ich wollte sagen jedenfalls, dass Leute sagen, dass der Podglas zu leise ist und es wirklich für uns sehr schwierig ist nachzuvollziehen, an welchem Punkt es leise wird und das hat dazu geführt, dass wir einfach in jedem Prozess, wo man die Datei irgendwie konvertieren muss oder Spuren zusammenfügen muss, in jedem Prozess knallen wir noch so ein bisschen drauf.
Ich höre dich nicht mehr, warte mal ganz kurz, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Florentin ist komplett weg.
Und das führt auch dazu, dass wir immer noch in jedem Prozess so ein bisschen zehn Prozent draufknallen und es eigentlich das lauteste, auf der Erde befindlichste Ding sein sollte, was es überhaupt gibt.
Aber das kann nicht sein. Also das kann nicht sein, es wird einfach noch immer leise.
So, ich habe mich ein bisschen in Rage geredet und Florentin ist inzwischen einfach komplett weg. Wir versuchen das mal in den Griff zu bekommen. Es liegt glaube ich dieses Mal nicht an mir.
Das stimmt mich positiv, ich greife zur Ukulele und mache ein bisschen Überbrückungsmusik. Das ist die Podcast-Ufo. Pause, die Technik-Pause ist vorbei. Pause. Ja, jetzt klingst du du wie vom Mars, aber ist okay. Ironie funktioniert auch in low quality. Also, warst du schon durch mit, warum wir so leise sind, oder können wir jetzt, was sollen wir machen? Ja, ich habe gesagt, dass wir nicht wissen, warum wir so leise sind. Hörst du mich noch? Hörst du mich überhaupt? Ja, ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll jetzt. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich reagieren soll. Ich weiß nicht, wann ich dran bin mit Reden, weil ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen delayed jetzt alles. Ich werde dich nochmal anrufen. Jetzt gleich. Nimm mich nicht an. Ja, Florentin, das ist gut, einen einfach wegzudrücken, wenn man einen Podcast aufnehmen will. Ja, hallo Florentin, ich spreche dir jetzt mal auf die Skype-Mailbox. Das wäre wirklich gut, wenn du kurz den Anruf annehmen könntest, einfach um so ein bisschen Abwechslung reinzubekommen in das Produkt heute. Ja, bis gleich. Da ist er doch. Hey. Jetzt geht's doch wieder. Sehr gut. Ich glaube, also wenn du, ich spreche jetzt drei, zwei, eins runter und wenn du die Eins hörst, sagst du bitte, sagst du bitte Stopp, okay? Okay. Fünf, vier, drei, zwei, eins. Stopp. Ja, okay, du hast ungefähr eine Sekunde haben wir versetzt, aber ist egal, das ist nicht schlimm. Okay, perfekt, okay. Gut, weiter geht's. Ja, sehr gut. Ja, erklär doch auch nochmal deine Sicht der Dinge, auf die leise Probleme. Auf welche? Gut, dass wir jetzt mal 40 Minuten drüber reden, über Dinge, von denen wir einfach keine Ahnung haben. Ich glaube, unser Problem ist, wir haben sehr viele Bauarbeiter als Hörer, die in einem wahnsinnig lauten Umfeld arbeiten oder was auch immer. Ich verstehe das nicht. Dann hörst du einfach zu Hause. Aber ich kenne das Problem tatsächlich auch, es gibt ein YouTube-Video von dieser Conan-Dokumentation über Conan O'Brien, wie er damals, als er nicht ins Fernsehen durfte, so eine Tour gemacht hat. Und dieses Video ist einfach extrem leise und es ist so frustrierend, weil du einfach vor deinem Rechner sitzt und du sagst, Leute, Ruhe bitte, ganz kurz, Ruhe, können die mal kurz 90 Minuten Ruhe machen und dann kommt wieder eine Wespe oder irgendein Scheiss durch die Gegend oder irgendwie meine Füße fangen an. Ja, oder man hat den Max wahnsinnig laut gemacht und dann plötzlich kommt ein Skype-Anruf und so und durch die ganze Wohnung schaltet dann dieser mächtige, laute Skype-Ton und reisst einem aus seinem Schlaf da, weil einfach der PC so laut gewacht ist.
Ja, die Community, wir wollten heute mal ein bisschen auf unsere Community eingehen, ein bisschen Community-Service machen, weil wir haben ja viele neue Freunde gefunden und wir wollten mal ein paar Fragen beantworten, die so von euch gekommen sind und …
Die hat Florentin alle parat. Die erste Frage, Frage, Florentin. Die, warte mal, ähm … Lass uns Fragen vielleicht ausdenken. Florentin, wie … Was ist dein Lieblingsmusical? Ja. Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Vielen Dank, Marina, für diese Frage. Mein Lieblingsmusical ist Grease.
Da mag ich am liebsten diesen Song Tell me more, tell me more, did she put up a fight? Der ist sehr gut. Die Stelle gefällt dir auch sehr gut, weil du dich da selber mit identifizieren kannst. Ja, vor allem, das ist ja ein Lied, also die beiden Hauptfiguren gehen auf ein Date und dann gehen sie wieder voneinander. Du siehst es ganz klar, mir fehlen die Fachbegriffe hier. Das ist ein Metieren, den ich mich nicht auskenne. Also sie gehen zusammen machen, also verbringen Zeit miteinander und dann hören sie auf, Zeit miteinander zu verbringen. Sport, das nennt man Sport. Sport und dann sind sie wieder voneinander entfernt, also nicht mehr zusammen, aber also, ne, örtlich getrennt. Jeder ist in seinem persönlichen Raum ein Zeitloch geschehen. Ich habe in der Tat auch, ach so, sorry, ich weiß nicht, wann du vorbei bist mit der Stichenerzählung. Nein, und dann kommt ja dieser Song, wo dann die Freunde der jeweiligen Person sie ausfragen, hey, wie lief denn das Date, wie lief denn das Date, tell me more, did you put up a fight? Und jetzt mal ganz kurz hier einhaken, ganz kurz, tell me more, tell me more, did she put up a fight? Erzähl mir, erzähl mir, hat sie sich gewehrt? Ist das wirklich die erste Frage, die einem einfällt, wenn man von dem Date zurückkommt? Weil man direkt davon rausgeht, dass sie geraped wurde. Aber ich stelle mir auch so vor, dieser ganze Chorfreunde, did you put up a fight? What the fuck, Steve? Was ist das für eine Frage, Steve? Oh mein Gott! Wir haben gesagt, wir fragen, ob sie Hähnchen gehalten haben und ob sie sich geküsst haben und welches Eis sie gegessen haben. Du fragst, hat sie sich gewährt? Hast du eigentlich einen Schaden? Wir haben gesagt, keine Improvisation, Steve! Damn it! God fucking damn it, man! You ruined it again! Es ist übrigens so, ich habe damals auch in mehreren Musicals mitgespielt, so regional. Mehreren! Tatsächlich in drei Stück habe ich mitgespielt. Insgesamt ist mir gerade auch aufgefallen. Erschreckend. Und in einem habe ich sogar die Hauptrolle gespielt. Und ich habe neulich mal irgendwie vor ein paar Wochen... Soll ich dir meine Kondome leihen? Ich glaube, in zwei Wochen leihen ... Ich hab die nötiger. Und vor zwei Wochen ist mir so aufgefallen, okay, das war ganz cool eigentlich. Die Story war bestimmt auch ganz geil. Da habe ich mir bei Wikipedia die Story nochmal durchgelesen. Und mir ist erschreckend klar geworden, dass ich damals, obwohl die Hauptrolle gespielt habe, die Story nicht ganz verstanden habe und nicht ganz genau wusste, was ich da gerade eigentlich mache und warum ich das eigentlich singe. Und ich weiss ja auch nicht, also irgendwie hat es mich nie so das Stück gepankt, dass es mich wirklich bis zum Ende interessiert hätte und ich wirklich die Story mitverfolgt habe. Also ich konnte den Text auswählen. Wenn nicht mal die Darsteller sich für die Geschichte interessieren, dann glaube ich, hat man inhaltlich echt ein Problem. Das ist auch, wenn die Lokaljournalisten schon aufgeben, das Stück wieder zu erzählen. Einfach sagen, einfach sich irgendwann auf andere Dinge, auf die Feuerwehr, die in der letzten Reihe sitzt, oder auf den Kuchenverkauf in der Pause konzentriert, anstatt auf die Story. Dann weiß man schon, okay, diese Story war vielleicht ein bisschen zu heavy für Zwölfjährige. Weiß man nicht. Oh, hier habe ich eine Frage von Simon, der fragt, gibt es die Intro-Musik irgendwo? Ist die Creative Commons Lizenz? Ja, ist sie. Sie ist Creative Commons. Aber es gab nur eine Kopie auf der Welt und die haben wir, die läuft nur auf Florentin. Wir haben die selber gemacht. Ja, aber er will das ja für sein Filmprojekt. Wir haben die selber gemacht. Aber wir können es dir nicht zukommen lassen. Aber du kannst sie von uns klauen gerne. Dann ist sie geklaut, aber du kannst sie gerne von uns klauen. Aber du musst darunter sprechen, in deinem Film, Klammer auf, C, Klammer zu, das Podcastufo.com. Falsch zitieren, das ist wichtig. Mensch, es wird ja bald wieder Winter, ne? Jetzt, der Sommer ist hinter uns, wir haben den Sommer endlich hinter uns gelassen, endlich wird es wieder kälter, die Nächte kommen früher, es wird wieder Winter und damit kommt auch die grosse Zeit der Heizung. Ja, ich bin schon ganz gespannt, was jetzt kommt. Du hast mich komplett verloren, ich bin da Heizungen so raus. Die Heizungen werden wieder angedreht, es wird wieder kuschelig, warm und ich habe mir letztens überlegt, ob ich meine Heizung anmachen soll und da ist mir eine Geschichte eingefallen und zwar die Geschichte, wie ich das erste Mal beim Neo Magazin war, das erste Mal zum Neo Magazin in die Redaktion gekommen bin. Ich glaube, da warst du auch dabei und ich weiß nicht, ob du dich noch daran erinnern kannst. Wir hatten massive Heizungsprobleme und die hat wahnsinnig krasse Geräusche gemacht, stimmt das? Da haben wir auch mal die Phase. Ja, auch das. Aber wenn du dich daran erinnerst, möchte ich dich fragen, wie du dich daran erinnerst und welchen Eindruck ich auf dich gemacht habe. Weil das war wirklich das allererste Mal, dass ich in der Redaktion des Neo Magazins war. Natürlich meine grossen Helden waren alle da. Und ich. Und ich. Matthias Borchers und du. Und da kam ich an, tatsächlich gerade mit dem Flugzeug geflogen, das zweite Mal in meinem Leben überhaupt im Flugzeug geflogen, kam ich da an in Köln und hatte dann meine grosse Reisetasche dabei, weil ich auch nicht wusste, wie lange ich bleiben soll, deswegen habe ich mal für vier Wochen geparkt einfach und habe alles mitgenommen, was ich brauche, die Poolnudel über der Schulter gehabt, alles dabei. und dann habe ich meine Tasche, dann kam ich rein ins Zimmer und habe meine Tasche abgestellt, einfach so.
Und dann hat mir so eine junge Dame dann gesagt, ah ja, das ist die Redaktion, so hier, da kannst du dich hinsetzen.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, und das weiß ich noch, dass das nicht so gut ankam, habe ich noch gesagt, okay, cool, vielen Dank, aber kann ich meine Tasche von der Heizung wegstellen? Da ist Schokolade drin. Änder ich mich nicht mehr noch. Ich weiß noch den Blick, den sie mir zugeworfen hat, diesen, Alter, was ist denn mit ihr los? Das Erste, was du sagst, ist, kann ich meine Tasche bitte weg von der Heizung stellen, weil ich habe Schokolade mitgebracht. Also der professionellste mögliche Eindruck, den man machen kann. Vor allem, es klingt so, als ob du nur Schokolade in dieser Tasche hast, als ob die ganze Tasche von einem grossen Schokoladenstück besetzt ist. Ja, und vor allem die Vorstellung, dass diese ganze Schokolade dann schmilzt und da so ein grosses Schokoladenmeer hin und her schwappt in meiner Tasche und ich panisch versuche. Und Leute sich auf die Stühle stellen, weil die Redaktion überführt wird von einem Schokoladenunglück. Nee, aber weiß ich nicht mehr, kann ich mich gar nicht daran erinnern. Kannst du dich nicht mehr daran erinnern? Ich weiß nur, dass ich eine Woche lang oder so einfach sehr böse angeguckt, zum Beispiel bei Fremden, die in der Redaktion zum ersten Mal sind immer, mir rühre ich einfach sehr lange sehr böse an, in der Hoffnung, dass ich sie so vergraule und ich will mein Revier irgendwie verteidigen. Aber hatte ich bei dir irgendwie nie das Bedürfnis, weil ich mir dachte, okay, der wird dir keine Probleme machen. Der hat Schokolade in seiner Tasche, der ist nett. Ja. Wir müssen auch ganz kurz mal, danke schön für diese Anekdote kurz. Danke gerne, Eif, ich habe einfach was reingeworfen. Ich finde es auch toll, dass du einfach so, dass du so plötzlich so Sachen einschlägst, so Wege einschlägst, aber ich folge dir einfach auf diese Wege, da bin ich offen für Neues. Aber ich würde kurz auch in einen anderen Weg einschlagen. Ich glaube, wir kennen uns jetzt schon so lange, wir können uns vertrauen einfach. Ich glaube, wir können gegeneinander vertrauen, dass es auch wohin führt. Und zwar würde ich gerne Folgendes ansprechen. Wir haben vor ein paar Wochen mal irgendwann gesagt, wir wollen gerne mit euch zusammen ein Hörertreffen machen, auch dem Humorkongress Basel. Das soll ein riesen Podcast-UFO-Event werden. Wir wollen den Weg dahin begleiten mit einer Kamera, wir wollen 90 Minuten daraus machen, einen ganz komischen Arthouse-Film, vielleicht einfach, wie wir 90 Minuten lang weinen, in einem Auto sitzen, uns mit Farbe anmalen. 90 Minuten lang die Haare kämmen im Konstruktion. Für ein Kunstprojekt, ein komisches Formanspruch. Nee, wir wollten einfach das begleiten und vielleicht auch so einen Podcast-Ufo-Film machen. Wir wollten versuchen, das irgendwie groß zu machen und euch da was auch mitzugeben und im Gegenzug eure Spenden abzugrapschen. Und es sind wirklich Spenden eingetroffen dafür, für dieses tolle Event. Und im Nachhinein ist es jetzt klar geworden, dass der Humorkongress Basel anscheinend die exklusivste, geilste Veranstaltung der Welt sein muss, weil die Karten kosten Tausende Euros. Es ist unfassbar. Genau, es gab nämlich leider keine Karten mehr. Wir wollten eigentlich zu diesem Humorkongress, aber es gab leider überhaupt keine Karten mehr.
Es stimmt auch so nicht ganz.
Die sind einfach nur wahnsinnig teuer geworden.
Und es könnten mir leider nicht kommen.
Und Stefan hat sich schon zurückgezogen.
Nein, ich höre dich noch.
Der Statement seines Anwalts liegt hier.
Hey, hör auf zum Bild in meine Glote rein.
Du erzählst auch noch alles, was ich auch schon erzählt habe, vor einer Minute.
Das finde ich ein enormes Delay.
Und das ist ein, was wir jetzt hier im Moment habenst auch noch alles, was ich auch schon erzählt habe, vor einer Minute.
Das würde ich ein enormes Delay.
Wir brechen das nochmal ab an der Stelle vielleicht einfach.
Ich rufe dich nochmal an kurz.
Ja, sehr gut, da sind wir doch wieder.
Auch gut, dass du meine Anrufe einfach nicht annimmst.
Wo man sich auch denkt, es wäre vielleicht ein bisschen hilfreich.
Ich habe gerade keine Zeit.
Das wäre auch geil, wenn du die ganze Zeit das vortäuscht, Probleme mit Skype zu haben,
aber einfach nur Termine blödgelegt hast und zwischen zwei Podcasts und herspringst.
Geil! Doppelt so viele Podcasts in gleicher Zeit, das ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Ja, aber zwei Freunde weniger einfach.
Ich habe auch keinen Bock mehr, mit dir was zu machen.
Willst du noch mal anfangen oder?
Nö.
Willst du noch mal anfangen und ich mache eine traurige Musik dazu? Ja, genau, aber wir lassen es aber auch drin vorher, einfach damit ihr jetzt zweimal, damit ihr jetzt unser Leid mal ein bisschen mitspürt, erzählen wir einfach Anekdoten jetzt doppelt. Es ist so, wir wollten noch Karten haben, gerne, wir wollten eure Spendengelder nicht verunglimpfen, sondern wir wollten wirklich die nutzen, um Karten zu besorgen, für dieses tolle Event, aber leider kosten die Milliarden Euro, die sind wahnsinnig teuer. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da gemacht wird in Basel, was da für drei Tage für eine Murder-Party abgeht, aber es muss unfassbar gut sein und ich weiß nicht, was die da alles machen, aber es ist wahnsinnig teuer und wir haben Bling Bling Basel, wie man es ja in unseren Kreisen nennt. Wir kriegen das Geld einfach nicht zusammen und ich meine, ihr habt wahnsinnig viel Gespendet, danke dafür, aber wir schicken euch das jetzt erstmal alles zurück, das ganze Geld. Aber, Florentin hat jetzt Mörder die Idee für euch, haben wir uns ausgedacht, Florentin will euch präsentieren jetzt, was wir stattdessen machen wollen, um euch zu entschädigen. Das ist so eine unangenehme Situation, lass uns mal diese unangenehme Situation ein bisschen zelebrieren. Wir haben Geld von euch bekommen, was echt super geil ist und super nett ist, und wir haben tatsächlich mehr Geld bekommen, als wir erwartet haben. Und da nochmal cool, vielen Dank an die Community auch einfach. Aber wir sind einfach zu unverantwortlich, um mit diesem Geld wirklich gut umgehen zu können. Das ist einfach eine unangenehme Situation. Aber wir haben uns was anderes überlegt, und zwar ... Meine erste Reaktion, meine erste Arschlochreaktion war, gut, die haben keinen Verwendungszweck bei der Spende angegeben, wir zahlen es denen einfach nicht zurück. Wir haben keinen gültigen Vertrag, nur das abgeschlossen, deswegen halten wir das Geld. Das sind meine kurzen Arschlochmomente, wo ich denke, wo ich so ein Bling-Bling-Augen habe. So Basel-Augen nennt man die auch, ja. Basel-Augen. Nein, wir sind hier immer auf der Suche nach interessanten Gästen und interessanten neuen Impulsen, die wir diesem Podcast geben können. Und letzte Woche war ja im Neo Magazin zu Gast die Rocket Beans. Rocket Beans. Und da haben wir uns überlegt, wie wäre es denn, wenn wir unseren Roadtrip anstatt nach Basel einfach nach Hamburg planen würden. Wir fahren dorthin, wir filmen die Autofahrt, wir filmen unser Hotel, wir filmen alles, was in dem Hotel passiert. und wir nehmen exklusiv Podcasts auf mit den Rocket Beans, so viele wie es geht, einzeln, zusammen, wie auch immer. Und wir moderieren Moin Moin, das wissen sie jetzt noch nicht. Aber wir machen das einfach. Wir versuchen dort so viel, wir versuchen den kompletten Takeover zu starten. Wir versuchen das hinzukriegen, weil wir auch gemerkt haben, dass bei euch in unserer Community einige Leute sind, die Rocket Beans Fans sind. Und es sind einfach total sympathische, coole Typen, mit denen wir uns gut unterhalten können und mit denen wir eine Menge Spaß haben können, deswegen wollen wir das durchziehen, ich hoffe, es ist okay für euch, dass wir jetzt so ein bisschen Wir hoffen, es ist auch okay für euch Rocket Beans, dass wir das einfach mal so entschieden haben. Ja, das ist jetzt erstmal zweitrangig. Aber ich glaube, das wird eine ganz coole Sache und so können wir auch unser großes Zweitprojekt nämlich starten, nämlich das YouTube-Ofo, unseren neuen YouTube-Channel, den wir starten werden, mit Blogs, Vlogs, Schminktipps, Follow Me Around, Fick the Facts About Me, Fick the Facts About You, Fick the Facts About You, Fick the Facts About You, Fick the Facts About You, Vitamin Bonbons. Genau, get ready with me, get ready without me, get not ready, goddammit, I don't have any time to get ready, I don't give a shit about you, die ganzen ganzen geilen Videos. She put up a fight, how to date rape on the first, how to, I rape on the first day. How to participate in musicals, and you don't know how, what the plot is. Die ganzen geilen Geschichten kommen da einfach aus. Ja, all das. Stefan Titzes Geid zum Musical Da muss ich auch noch mal sagen, wir müssen da noch mal drüber sprechen. Ich war am Wochenende in den Kartoffelsalat, wo wir gerade bei geilem Plot sind. Ich muss da noch mal kurz drüber sprechen. Der offiziell schlechteste Film an der Zeit. Ja, genau, von einem Divisalat. Und ich muss ganz kurz dazu sagen, Leute, geht in diesen Film. Das ist wirklich, es ist ohne scheiss eine Erfahrung. ist auch ein bisschen so wie die letzte Folge von uns. Unterhaltung ist ja vielschichtig und vielseitig. Und es muss ja nicht immer nur ein gutes Produkt kann unterhalten, sondern ein sehr schlechtes Produkt kann dann auch genauso gut unterhalten, vielleicht nur in die andere Richtung halt, einen Rüten machen. Und ja, das ist wirklich ein Erlebnis, was ihr auf jeden Fall mal mitnehmen solltet. Vor allem, ihr seht andere Filme auch mit anderen Augen. Also man sieht dann auch andere schlechte Filme, sieht man einfach auch besser. Und sehr gute Filme feiert man dann richtig, weil man denkt, geil, dass es auch, dass die Welt gibt, auch gute Filme gibt. Und ich mag auch Filme, die es einem erlauben, sich ausserhalb des Filmes zu unterhalten. Also zum Beispiel solche Spiele wie Wer zählt die meisten geklauten Witze mit? Wer findet die meisten Stellen, an denen einfach das Bild unscharf ist, wer findet die meisten Szenen, an denen Dagi Bee tatsächlich eine absolut akzeptable Schauspielerin ist. Und ich habe kein Wort verstanden. Ich weiß nicht, ob es am Mielach oder am Kino. Ich war zu leise. Die haben einfach genuschelt und hatten dann keinen Bock mehr, die Szene nochmal neu aufzunehmen. Und ich habe dann manchmal gedacht, das ist jetzt Outtake, das ist der ganze Film ein riesen Outtake, den wir uns da zeigen. Und dann hab ich auch das Gefühl gehabt, dass die ersten zehn Minuten, da hat sich jemand richtig Mühe gegeben mit Color Grading, aber irgendwann hat es einfach keinen Bock mehr. Oder die Zahl, das Taxometer, das Gradometer lief plötzlich einfach ab und dann miedelzehn haben die keinen Bock mehr gehabt, das irgendwie die Farben zu korrigieren. Und dann war der Film einfach farbunkorrigiert, dass einfach so Dinge,, die einem dann auffallen plötzlich, die man auch an einem Filmler zu schätzen weiß plötzlich. Dass man Dinge hört, dass man Sätze verstehen kann, weil sich jetzt zu schätzen. Das ist echt unfassbar. Aber ganz geil. Geile Erfahrung. Ja, absolut. Ich habe ihn auch gerne gesehen, eigentlich. Kein Problem. Teil zwei wird bestimmt folgen. Ja. ähm. Ich lass dich kurz mal alleine, ich lass dich kurz mal an der langen Leine, warum was passiert. Apropos, Smisma, ähm, Smisma, ich war ja im Urlaub. Ja, soll ich vielleicht kurz mal meine Fisch-Anekdote erzählen? Ja, endlich, die Teaserst du, an diesem Mal sagst du heute im Prinzip. Ich glaube, ich habe die Teaser einmal rausgeschnitten, weil die mir ein bisschen zu awkward waren, aber ich habe mich jetzt dazu durchgerungen, endlich mal die Fischanekdote zu erzählen. Ich bin froh, ich würde mich freuen, wenn du so ein bisschen reingrätscht und wir dazu ein cooles Bit jetzt draus machen aus den folgenden, aus den folgenden zwei Stunden Fischanekdote. Okay, lass doch jetzt einfach mal ein Bit machen, okay? Komm, lass dich mal ein bisschen … Wama, bit. Fischanekdote, wie das Podcast-Ofo Fischanekdote.
Blub, blub, blub, blub. Und zwar war das so, ich war auf der Suche nach einem neuen Mitbewohner.
Ich dachte mir, gut alleine wohnen hat auch viele Nachteile, zum Beispiel, man hat einfach keine Lebewesen mehr um sich herum.
Und du sagst, neuer Mitbewohner, was ist mit dem Letzten passiert?
Er ist gestorben, er ist gestorben, ich habe den Föhn in die Badewanne fallen lassen. Wo ich mich auch frage, das ist eine lange Tweet-Idee, die ich hier noch halte. Erste Ablenkung. Wir zählen die Ablenkung mit. Wir zählen mit. Ungeklaute Tweets. Und ich habe mir überlegt, wenn ich jetzt einen Föhn in die Badewanne fallen lasse, stirbt der Mensch da drin. Wenn ich ein Föhn in die Nordsee fallen lasse, sterben dann alle Badegäste in der Nordsee oder warum nicht? Auf der anderen Seite, beim Gewitter soll man ja auch immer das Bad verlassen und das Meer verlassen, glaube ich. Und sich Knoblauch umheizt. Genau. Es ist auch so, diese Gewitterregeln sind auch so komplett random einfach. Man soll sich unter einen Türrahmen stellen, aber gar keinen Fall in die Nähe einer Tischtennisplatte kommen. Und auf jeden Fall Spanisch sprechen. Hört auf, Deutsch sprechen, Spanisch sprechen. Okay. Ja, und dann habe ich mich dafür entschieden, ich hätte jetzt schon mal ein Aquarium und habe überlegt, woran ist es gescheitert. Ich fand es eigentlich vom Prinzip her ganz geil. Das Konzept-Aquarium ist geil. Aber was stört mich daran? Ja, ich bin auch lernfähig und reflektiert. Ich habe mir gedacht, das Saubermachen hat mir nicht gefallen, diese vielen boring Fische, die einfach wahnsinnig hässlich manchmal waren, einfach langweilig waren. Das war ein schlechtes Ensemble. Das hat nicht gepasst, die Chemie hat nicht gepasst. Die Story war gut, aber die Darsteller waren nicht so geil. Die Chemie hat wortwörtlich nicht gepasst. Ich glaube, am Ende war es einfach wirklich giftig. Yay, Fischgag! Der Funke ist einfach nicht gesprungen, so wie beim Föhn. Bisschen weit weg, aber ganz gut. Und deswegen dachte ich mir dieses Mal, es muss ein sehr kleines Aquarium her, was nicht so pflegeintensiv ist, heißt man muss Wasser wechseln oder Wasserwechsel sind halt sehr einfach und der einzige Fisch, der reinpasst, ist gleichzeitig der geilste Fisch, den es überhaupt auf der Welt gibt für Aquarien, der siamesische Kampffisch. Das ist der krasseste Fisch, der es überhaupt gibt. Der heisst wirklich Kampffisch, weil er zum Kämpfen erzogen wurde. Damals haben die in Taiwan und Vietnam diese Fische gezüchtet auf Aggression. Also die haben wirklich die aggressivsten Fische nur sich weiter vermehren lassen und irgendwann auch ausgesetzt. Und die sind wahnsinnig aggressiv, weil die einfach zum Kämpfen gemacht wurden und gezwungen wurden. Und die sind jetzt immer noch, also die nachfolgenden Fische, die man jetzt hat, sind immer noch wahnsinnig aggressiv. Und er ist auch bis an die Kiemen bewaffnet. Ja, komplett.
So eine Knarre immer und so ein Fuck-Life-Tattoo.
So ein Bandana, so ein Kopftuch, Goldkette.
Eine Augenklappe, ich weiß nicht, wo er die hat.
Einschüchterung ist schon die halbe Miete bei dem Kampf.
Und dann kam das Problem.
Die richtig geilen Kampffische kann man sich nicht im Laden kaufen, sondern muss sie sich im Internet bestellen.
Schwarzmarkt.
Und dann gibt es, kurz Schleichwerbung, es gibt nur einen Fischshop, wo man sich das bestellen kann im Internet und der heißt Jans Kampffischshop. Das ist kein Schatz. Lass uns bitte Jan interviewen. Wer auch immer dieser Jan ist, lass uns bitte Jan interviewen, der gesagt hat, weißt du was, ich verkaufe jetzt einfach Kampffische, ich baue keine Mandeln mehr an. Ich mache in Kampffische. Das ist ganz geil. There is always money in the battlefish. Und dann habe ich dem halt, dann hat er halt gesagt, der importiert die dann wirklich aus Taiwan, da wo die herkommen. Und das Ding war, der hat halt eine Deadline geschrieben. Er hat gesagt, bis zu dem und dem Punkt müsst ihr die Fische bestellen, sonst kriegt ihr die nicht mehr. Und dann habe ich ganz viele Mails in geschrieben, weil er nie geantwortet hat, habe ich ganz viele Mails hin geschrieben, weil ich halt noch diese Deadline mitnehmen wollte. Die Fische haben übernommen. Irgendwann habe ich ihn angerufen. Die haben gewonnen. Fische haben ihn getötet. Und dann habe ich ihn angerufen und er war so mega angepisst und dachte mir, was ist Jan Scumfish Shop für ein, was ist das für ein komischer Nachname und zweitens, was ist das für ein Arschlochtyp eigentlich, warum ist er jetzt so angepisst? Und er hat gesagt zu mir, hör mal, was ist eigentlich mit dir los, warum schreibst du mir so viele E-Mails? Und er hat mir die ganze Zeit E-Mails zurückgeschrieben, die aber alle nicht angekommen sind und er hat mich für den komischsten Creepy-Typen der Welt gehalten, weil er einfach, weil ich einfach mal so einen Monolog gehalten habe und immer auch gefühlt auf meine Mails geantwortet habe, weil ich immer halt jeden Tag neue Mails geschrieben habe, auch mit neuen Formulierungen und so. Und er hat es die ganze Zeit gewonnen, also mega awkward fing das Ganze an. Und dann kommen wir zum Finale dieser ganzen Geschichte, die führt dahin, Fische verschicken, Lebewesen verschicken, erstens mit so awkward Typen wie mir, kann man das nicht machen, ich werde es auch nie wieder machen. Man kriegt da dann, die werden mit Go Express verschickt. Das ist so ein Kurierdienst einfach, die Overnight-Dinge machen, die konnten einem aber nicht genau sagen, wann das kommt. Und da bin ich extra für aufgestanden, weil es hieß, die können von sieben bis zehn und dreißig kommen. Ich war bis zehn Uhr, konnte ich noch hierbleiben. Das klingt jetzt schon wieder wie ein Pixar-Film. Es tut mir leid, aber es klingt einfach jetzt schon wieder wie ein Pixar-Film. Es ist Fisch, der Kampffisch. Ich erzähle eins zu eins, Fisch Fisch. Wird verschickt und kommt dann irgendwie falsch an, verliebt sich dann bla bla bla und musste seinem ursprünglichen Typ wieder zurück. Er ist ausgebildet, der Kampfschiff, Fisch, er ist eines Tages auf dem Strand aufgewacht und war einfach der beste Kampffisch der Welt und zieht jetzt groß in die weite Abenteuerwelt raus. Und er knabbert sich dann durch sein Paket durch und fällt dann da irgendwie in der Cola Light in dem Flugzeug von irgendeiner reichen Dame. Fällt in den Rhein und stirbt, weil er rein ist, einfach direkt. Tot, ja. Wird dann irgendwie aussersehen getrunken von einer reichen Dame, die hat dann irgendwie eine Blinddamenoperation und dann lernt er irgendwie eine süße Krankenschwester kennen und so entwickelt sich die Story dann, bis er irgendwann tatsächlich bei Stefan Titzer ankommt und dann passiert Folgendes. Nee, und dann war es so, dass ich zur Arbeit musste und mir dachte, scheiße, was soll ich jetzt machen?
Aber ich muss halt zur Arbeit.
Und dann kam auf dem Weg zur Arbeit dann der Anruf.
Bring, bring!
Ja, hallo, hier ist der Kurierdienst.
Wir haben einen Fisch, sie kriegen jetzt einen Fisch.
Und da habe ich gesagt, ja, ich ...
Das ist die beste Botschaft aller Zeiten.
Sie kriegen jetzt einen Fisch.
Ich weiß, aber ich bin jetzt nicht zu Hause.
Sie kriegen ein Lebewesen und sind nicht zu Hause.
Und wie soll man dann reagieren?
Und Ja, ich ... Das ist die beste Botschaft aller Zeiten. Ich weiß, aber ich bin jetzt nicht zu Hause. Sie kriegen ein Lebewesen und sind nicht zu Hause. Und wie soll man dann reagieren? Durch das denkt man so, fuck ja, nein, ich bin halt nicht zu Hause, ich muss halt arbeiten. Und dann war der mega verwirrt und verunsichert, was er jetzt machen soll mit dem Fisch, den er halt in der Hand hatte, weil die haben halt auch nicht immer Fische, die die versenden. Die versenden halt Pakete ganz normal, aber nicht Fische. Und dann hat er das meinem Nachbarn gegeben, auch Anraten von mir. Und dann dachte ich mir, gut, du musst halt schnell zu Hause sein, weil du musst diesen Fisch halt ins Aquarium setzen, der kann eigentlich in diesem Paket die ganze Zeit bleiben. War dann aber ausgerechnet natürlich Sonntag, man kennt das Schicksal. Es war Sonntag, wo ich halt mega lang arbeiten musste und dachte mir, die ganze Zeit schon Bilder SMS an meinen Kollegen geschrieben hat, fuck, ich muss los, mein Fisch wartet zu Hause. Und bringt den Nachbarn um, der ist bewaffnet. Der muss was zu essen haben, sonst rastet der aus. Ja, was dann dazu führte, dass ich dann schnell nach Hause musste, ja, dann wurde der ausgerechnet bei dem Nachbarn abgegeben, der nicht da war, der nicht zu Hause war. Und dann habe ich dem Post-it an die Tür geklebt und mit den Worten, könnten Sie mir meinen Fisch bitte runterbringen. Und unter der Tür durchschieben einfach. Am besten noch heute, weil es ist, na ja, ein Fisch. Das führte dann dazu, dann bin ich nach unten gegangen und musste mich dann irgendwie beschäftigen, weil es war schon wirklich spät in der Nacht, mitten in der Woche halt. Und dann habe ich aber vergessen, die Tür richtig zuzumachen, was mega awkward war, weil irgendwann stand der Nachbar halt in meinem Wohnzimmer und ich sass da in Boxershorts irgendwie rum und dann kam einfach reingelaufen, weil die Tür halt offen war und hat mir mein Fisch ins Gesicht gehalten. Was war das für ein Fisch? Also war das einfach ein Paket? Das ist ein grosses Theroport-Paket. Es ist ein grosses Theroport.. Und der hatte da so eine Cookluke drin oder so? Nein. Da hatte ich vor, wo es von angeschaut.
Nein, er hat mit der Waffe auf mich gezeigt.
Ne, es ist einfach ein Styroporwürfel und da drin ist einfach, wie man das kennt, so ein ganz normaler Beutel mit Wasser und Luft drin für den Fisch.
Ja, der ist nicht ganz so anspruchsvoll, diese Dinger, deswegen ist es ganz okay und der kommt damit auch klar. Die hätten auch eine Woche überlebt.
Jans Kampfe-Shop hat mir dann auch erklärt, dass manche Fische sogar schon zwei Wochen überlebt haben in diesen Styroporboxen. Und dein Aquarium war auch noch nicht gekommen, das heißt, du hast dir einfach diese Plastiktüte auf die Kommode gestellt und das war's dann. Seitdem wohnt er bei mir in der Badewanne. In der Styroporbox, der gefährlichste Fisch der Welt, wohnt bei mir auf dem Fernseher. Ja, seitdem wohnt er bei mir und ihm geht's gut. Aber hat er einen guten Ausblick? Also hast du da auch geguckt, dass du ihn irgendwie so hinstellst, dass er irgendwie aus dem Fett zurück kann? Nee, aber ich habe so ganz viele coole Sachen reingestellt. Ich habe diese Ananas von SpongeBob. Deinen ATS-Tier hast du daneben gestellt. Genau, diese Ananas von SpongeBob, eine Buddha-Statue, ganz viele Sachen, die nie langweilig werden. Nee, es ist wirklich artgerecht eingerichtet und ihm geht's gut dem Fisch soweit. Ich kann euch mal ein Bild schicken. Ja, post doch mal ein Bild von deinem Kampffisch, dem gefährlichsten Fisch der Welt, wie er so eine Geste macht, wie er sich ... Wie er den Mittelfinger zeigt. You're next, you're next! Ja, oder sowas, die Mittelflosse zeigt. Ja, ganz geil, also Kampffische kann ich jedem empfehlen, coole Tiere, bin ich, großartige Tiere, wahnsinnig aggressiv, seid vorsichtig, und immer mit so ... Ihr müsst so einen Kettenhandschuh anziehen, wenn ihr das Aquarium sauber macht. Wenn man ihn streicheln will. Aber sonst ganz geil. Aber also, wenn du mal, sag ich mal, einen kurzen Moment für dich selbst haben möchtest in deinem Apartment, fragst du ihn dann, ob er kurz weggucken kann? Nee, ich leg ein Handtuch drüber. Ein Handtuch drüber. Sehr gut. Es tört dich auch immer total an, das Handtuch drüber zu legen, so Konditionierungsfelsen. Ja, und vor allem das Aquarium wackelt dann immer, weil er wahnsinnig aggressiv wird und gegen die Schwanz. Das ist echt krass, weil er mitmacht. Fische sind wahnsinnig dämlich und er sieht sich halt in der Aquariumscheibe und denkt, es wäre ein anderes Männchen, was der angreifen muss. Man kann nicht zwei Männchen in einem Aquarium halten, weil die töten sich sofort. In fünf Minuten sind die tot. Es gibt auch Videos im Internet von wahnsinnig grausam. Und der greift dann halt kontinuierlich, seitdem ich den habe, seit fünf Wochen, greift er kontinuierlich sein Spiegelbild an. Wird ihm das nicht langweilig oder ist das irgendwie auch ungesund für ein Tier? Der härteste Kampf seines Lebens. Sein grösster Feind war die ganze Zeit er selbst. Wie ein Pixar-Film, am Ende lernte die Direktion. Das ist doch gut. Lass mal Pixar-Autoren werden. Ja, lass uns einfach mal für ein Wochenende Pixar-Autoren werden. Finde ich auch eine gute Idee. Wir machen einfach so einen Workshop, ein Wochenende schreiben, einfach einen Pixar-Film durch. Aber hast du nicht auch so ein bisschen so einen Experimentierungsdrang, dass du sagst, so könnte er rein theoretisch auch in Tee überleben? Ja, habe ich. Wenn ich da jetzt so 22 Tebeutel reinhänge. Wie viel Föns kann ich hier reinmachen und wie viel Harspray? Genau, wie viel Mayonnaise könnte ich in das Aquarium tun, bevor er sagt, ich mag keine Mayonnaise. Ja, weiss ich nicht. Bin ich auf jeden Fall. Ich habe schon ein paar Teebeutel reingehalten, bis jetzt hast du ihm gefallen. Die sind wirklich nicht anspruchsvoll. Ich glaube, er könnte wirklich mit einem Glas Mayonnaise übernachten. Mal. Als Ferienlager. Mama, ich will jetzt Ferienlager wieder ins Mayonnaise kennen. Nee, das ist um zu teuer. Das ist um zu teuer, Jeff. Er heisst Jeff. Jeff? Ach so, du bist schon wieder im Pixar-Film, oder was? Wie sieht eigentlich das Drehbuch für Warly aus? Wie sieht eigentlich das Drehbuch von Kartoffelbrei-Salat aus? Wie sieht das Drehbuch eigentlich da aus? Weiß ich, es ist eine gute Feedline, aber es ist ein bisschen zu antruchsvoll für mich. Tut mir leid, ich muss noch ein paar Mal ins Mayonnaise-Comedy-Camp, bevor ich solche Setups verwandeln kann. Ah, gut gerettet, Applaus. Ja, ich werde berichten, wie es läuft mit dem Fisch. Ja, du kannst es ja zu einer regelmäßigen Rubrik machen, so der Stefan-Titze-Fisch-Report. What's up in the fish tank? Mach mal einen Wein von deinem Fisch. Ja, du kannst es ja zu einer regelmäßigen Rubrik machen, irgendwie so, der Stefan-Titze-Fish-Report. What's up in the fish tank?
Mach mal, mach mal einen Wein von deinem Fisch.
Ja, Weins habe ich auch noch nicht
ganz durchblickt. Also muss
es immer loopfähig sein?
Nee, es wird aber automatisch
geloopt halt nach. Ja, genau, das ist mir schon klar.
Das habe ich schon verstanden.
Hast du Snapchat eigentlich? Ich habe mal überlegt, ob ich hier
im Podcast mal meinen
Snapchat-Namen verrate, einfach damit es mehr Spaß macht, weil man kann ja auch, das ist ein bisschen wie so ein Abo-Service, also du kannst Leuten folgen und die können dann wirklich Videos raushauen und Fotos raushauen und Leute können das dann halt sehen. Fände ich ganz geil eigentlich. Macht mehr Spaß, glaube ich, wenn man mehr Leute hat, mit denen man da abhängt. Ja, gerne. Wir können mir auch gerne auf Snapchat folgen. Mein Snapchat-Name ist Stefan Titze. Ja, das ist kein Schade. Können wir das vielleicht mal ändern? Ich hätte gerne den Namen. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber der Name lächelt mich irgendwie an. Ja, nee, tut mir leid. Kann ich nicht so machen. Ist das nicht auch verboten? Das sind die Urkundenfälschungen. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie einen Dick-Pick verschickst mit meinem Namen. Das ist eine gute Idee. Das ist eine sehr gute Idee. Also, falls ihr Dickpicks vom echten Stefan Titzer haben wollt, dann folgt ihm auf Snapchat. Jode Problem. Wenn ihr dann Bilder von seinem Wasserballturnier haben wollt oder was Uncooles er sonst noch so am Wochenende macht, was ich nie machen würde, Wasserball spielen oder sonst irgendwelche komischen Spiele. Ich glaube, Wasserball ist wahnsinnig hart. Ich glaube, das wäre viel zu uncool noch. Kommt auf den Kalkgehalt an, glaube ich. Das kann auch angekommen sein. Ein Wassergag. Wasserballgag. Einer der wenigen Wassergag. Was ich mir letztens gedacht habe, es gibt ja unbeliebte Sportarten, zu Recht, und beliebte Sportarten. Und so Fussball ist halt wahnsinnig beliebt bei uns. Aber die Frage ist, also von der Berichterstattung, manchmal kriegt man ja auch was von anderen Sportarten mit, so bei Frauenfußball oder so, wenn halt die Deutschen gewinnen. Ich finde, du kannst sagen, die coolsten Sportarten sind die, wo die Kommentatoren flüstern, wie beim Tennis, und der schlägt den Ball und es ist sein fünftes Grand-Slam-Tonier. Und der Ball fliegt durch die Luft und auf die andere Seite und er kommt auf den Boden auf und er wird wieder zurückgeschlagen. Ohne Sätze, das Netz ist im Weg. Ich habe mich aber gefragt, weil ja manchmal dann so, wenn ganz krasse Sachen in einer anderen Sportart passieren, kriegt man die schon mit, irgendwie Olympiade, Deutschland gewinnt.
Was müsste mindestens in so einer Sportart passieren, damit man sie mitkriegt? Also zum Beispiel angenommen, man spielt jetzt keine Ahnung, irgendwie, ja, Wasserball, sagen wir mal, und da geht ein Spiel in dem Verhältnis aus, wie es bei Fußball 200 zu 0 wäre. Und sowas passiert einfach mal. Einmal in tausend Jahren geht so ein Spiel 200 zu 0 aus. Oder halt 800 zu 0, je nachdem, wie viel wertvoll ein Tor ist. Und die Wasserball-Community bringt dich um vor Freude. Ja, aber würden wir das mitbekommen? Weil es müssen ja ab und zu so richtig krasse Dinge in diesen kleinen Sportarten passieren, die wir ja gar nicht mitbekommen. Also irgendwie so achtzehn rote Karten. So nach vier Minuten muss das Spiel abgebrochen werden, weil alle Spieler vom Platz gestellt werden. Man schickt sich auch manchmal bei Facebook so Videos rum, wie halt irgendwer ein wahnsinnig geiles Tor im Fussball geschlossen hat. Und da frage ich mich auch, was müsste beim Schach passieren, dass ein Spielzug es viral macht? Also was muss da passieren? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Was muss der Läufer alles wegwämsen? Alles machen. Was für ein Drall braucht der Läufer, damit er sich einmal quäleses Spielfeld und dann noch ins Kreuzet. Damit er einmal einen ordentlichen Slam-Dank macht. Ja genau, das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage. Oder irgendeinem E-Sport. Wollen wir mal ein Schachspiel? Das ist alles möglich, wenn... Ja, wir können gerne Schach spielen. Ja, das wird die beste Podcast-Folge aller Zeiten. Turm auf A3.
Ja, können wir gerne machen.
Und da werden denn die Nerds von euch das so mega feiern werden und die ganze Zeit so richtig mitfiebern,
weil die sich das Bildig vorstellen können, wo gerade das Feld aussieht.
Ich habe mal Schach gespielt eine Zeit lang. Ich war ja mal im Schachclub tatsächlich.
Boah, wir sind so uncool.
Das war dann der Punkt, wo ich meine Kondome weggeworfen habe, wo ich mir gesagt habe,
nee, der Traum wird nicht mehr in Erfüllung gehen. Das war's. Aber ganz kurz, wie machst du das ein, mit welchem Bein steigst du als erstes ins Kondom? Bein? Ich habe den Kopf immer genommen. Erst über den Kopf und dann auf links ziehen und dann, okay. Ja, das ist ein ganz guter. Aber du hast schon einen Schuhlöffel auch dabei, oder was? Ich weiß nicht, wie weit man diesen Gang noch bringen kann. Falls euch noch was einfällt, schreibt es wie immer gerne in die Kommentare oder auch nicht. Lasst es einfach. Lasst es mal wieder. Bleibt mal so schön aktiv, wie ihr es jetzt gerade seid. Also das ist ganz toll. Wir kriegen von überall Lob, von allen anderen Leuten, anderen Podcastern, kriegen wir Lob für unsere tolle Community. Man kann auch immer einfach Dinge erfinden. Das merken die nie. Wir haben die beste Community. Ich glaube, bei Podcast UFO zu kommentieren, ist das Beste, was man machen kann, ohne Geld auszugeben. Glaube ich wirklich. Apropos Geld. Wie gesagt, wenn wir das mit dem Hamburg, also wir werden euch euer Geld jetzt zurücküberweisen, vielleicht, aber wenn wir das mit Hamburg noch machen wollen, dann müsst ihr uns ... Rechtlich abgesichert. Mit diesem Wort, rechtlich alles abgesichert. Mein Anwalt sitzt hier neben mir, er lächelt und nickt. Er nickt dir zu, nice one.
Er hat sich keine Sonnenbrille aufgesetzt.
Nee, und wir müssen auch wirklich Geld dann haben, um nach Hamburg zu fahren.
Und wir wollen zusammen da hinfahren, wollen ein Roadmovie machen und wollen da halt auch ein paar Folgen aufnehmen.
Und da müssen wir halt irgendwie auch nächtigen und da hinkommen und so.
Und wir hätten schon gern die erste Klasse.
Deswegen müsst ihr schon auch ein bisschen noch bei PayPal da spenden.
Wir geben euch auch nochmal die Kontinuier nochmal durch. Achtung, zum Mitschreiben. Bip, bup, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip. Also, überweist es reichlich. Und wir haben auch ein bisschen Flatter und so, also es ist nicht so, dass wir das unbedingt brauchen, aber es wäre natürlich cool, ein bisschen Unterstützung zu bekommen, um einen Werbeaufwand wiederkommens zu machen. Ja, wollen wir Flatter vielleicht einfach in der Löschung, da kommt nicht so viel dabei rum. Flatter ist ein Mikrodonations. Wir machen das ja auch nicht fürs Geld, lass uns mal nicht so kapitalistisch rüberkommen. Wir machen das ja auch einfach nur, wir machen das alles für die Hörer der vierten Klasse. Diese ganze Folge war nur der Hörer der vierten Klasse gewidmet. Alles klar. Sind wir jetzt eigentlich auch durch, oder geht es noch weiter? Nee, ich glaube, wir sind durch eigentlich. Ja, ich freue mich, war doch ganz okay mal wieder. Ja, war in Ordnung, okay.
Würde sagen, können wir mal wieder mal machen.
Wollen wir jetzt wieder eine Nachbesprechung machen?
Ohne uns selbst beschweren?
Was ist gerade eben passiert?
Kann man nicht was zurück von ...
So ein unsympathisches Arschloch dieses Mal.
Leute werden sich fragen, kam man nicht was zurück von Maxi?
Hat er noch irgendwas gesagt? Nee.
Kam von Rute was zurück auf Twitter? Von Rute kam irgendwas gesagt? Nee, kam von Ruth was zurück auf Twitter, den ...
Von Ruth kam was zurück, ja, Ruth hat gesagt, er mag mich.
Tun mir leid, Ruth, du bist leider ein zynisches Arschloch und wir werden, glaube ich, nie Freunde werden.
Sorry, Ruth.
Sorry, das Podcast-Ufo sagt sorry, wir sagen danke.
Das Podcast-Ufo ... Das Wort Kassuwo, Smith, nehmt ein Head-Up, Smith.